♪♪
>>> BIN LADEN DETERMINED TO
STRIKE IN U.S.
THOSE SEVEN WORDS APPEARED IN A
PRESIDENTIAL DAILY BRIEF MORE
THAN A MONTH BEFORE THE
SEPTEMBER 11th ATTACKS.
20 YEARS LATER, WE'RE LEARNING
NEW DETAILS ABOUT THAT FAMOUS
MEMO.
FORMER CIA OFFICER DAVID PRIEST
RECENTLY SPOKE WITH INTELLIGENCE
LEADERS AT THE TIME AS WELL AS
THE LEAD AUTHOR OF THE MEMO AND
PRIEST TWEETED THIS, SHE TOLD
ME, THAT'S THE MEMO WRITER, THAT
SHE REGRETS NOT HITTING THE MAIN
POINT HARDER.
SHE SAID I'VE THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT HOW THE ARTICLE READS.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER TO SAY
ALL THESE THREATS WE HAVE SEEN
ALL SUMMER COULD BE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND DAVID PRIEST
IS JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
HE WAS THE DAILY INTELLIGENCE
BRIEFER TO FBI DIRECTOR ROBERT
MUELLER AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
JOHN ASHCROFT DURING THE GEORGE
W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE PRESIDENT'S BOOK
OF SECRETS THE UNTOLD STORY OF
INTELLIGENCE BRIEFINGS TO
AMERICA'S PRESIDENTS.
AS YOU POINT OUT, THIS IS REALLY
THE MOST FAMOUS ONE, DAVID.
AND IT'S FASCINATING TO HEAR
THIS STORY REALLY OF REGRET.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> YEAH.
THAT WHOLE SUMMER I WAS IN THE
COUNTERTERRORIST CENTER ALONG
WITH THAT AUTHOR AND A SMALL
GROUP OF OTHERS WHO WERE
ANALYZING THE THREATS TO THE
UNITED STATES FROM TERRORIST
GROUPS.
AND THERE WAS NO DOUBT IN
ANYONE'S MIND THAT A MAJOR
ATTACK WAS COMING.
THIS WAS NOT A SURPRISE.
AND THERE HAD BEEN A SERIES OF
PIECES PUT IN FRONT OF THE
PRESIDENT IN TO THE PRESIDENT'S
DAILY BRIEF WHICH CONTAINS MANY
OTHER THINGS AS WELL, BUT WE
WERE CERTAINLY PUSHING THE
PRESIDENT ON THE IDEA THAT BIN
LADEN IS UP TO SOMETHING.
AL QAEDA IS PLANNING SOMETHING.
THERE WERE UPWARDS OF 40
DIFFERENT PIECES IN THE
PRESIDENT'S DAILY BRIEF IN THE
NINE MONTHS OR SO BEFORE
SEPTEMBER 11th TALKING ABOUT BIN
LADEN AND WHAT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS PIECE IS REFERRING TO THERE
IS THE FACT THAT THIS SPECIFIC
PIECE ON AUGUST 6th, THE ONE THE
9/11 COMMISSION PUBLISHED AND
BECAME FAMOUS IT SPEAKS
SPECIFICALLY BIN LADEN'S INTENT
TO ATTACK IN THE UNITED STATES
AND DOES WITH HISTORICAL FEEL,
WHAT HAS BIN LADEN SAID, WHAT
HISTORICAL INTELLIGENCE
REPORTING DO WE HAVE SUGGESTING
THIS BUT SHE DIDN'T ACTUALLY SAY
OUT RIGHT, MR. PRESIDENT,
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU ALL SUMMER ABOUT THIS
HEIGHTENED THREAT, IT ALL COULD
BE ABOUT THE UNITED STATES
ITSELF.
NOW, SHE'S UNDER NO ILLUSIONS
THAT WOULD HAVE NECESSARILY MADE
A DIFFERENCE.
THE PRESIDENT SEES FIVE OR SIX
DIFFERENT PIECES EVERYDAY IN THE
PRESIDENT'S DAILY BRIEF.
MANY OF WHICH HAVE THREATS FROM
AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT IT'S ONE OF THE MANY THINGS
THAT MANY OF US WORKING THERE
LOOK BACK AND SAY COULD WE HAVE
DONE ONE THING MORE TO HELP
PREVENT THESE ATTACKS.
>> IT IS FASCINATING TO KNOW
THAT THERE WERE SO MANY OF THESE
MEMOS.
WE KNOW OF THIS ONE, IT IS THE
MOST FAMOUS, BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THERE WERE DOZENS
LEADING UP AND PRESIDENT BUSH
DID ASK ABOUT IT.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT WASN'T ON HIS
RADAR BIN LADEN AND AL QAEDA.
CAN YOU JUST TAKE US THROUGH HOW
THIS MEMO WAS ASSEMBLED?
>> SURE.
WELL, THERE HAD BEEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION TO AL QAEDA, AS I
MENTIONED.
AND MEMORIES DIFFER AS TO THE
EXACT GENESIS OF THIS ONE.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER AT THE TIME
CONDI RICE SUGGESTED THAT THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF ASKED FOR IT.
OTHERS REMEMBER THAT THE
BRIEFER, MICHAEL MOREL LATER
BECAME THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF
THE CIA, THAT MICHAEL ACTUALLY
THOUGHT THIS WOULD FILL A GAP IN
THE PRESIDENT'S KNOWLEDGE.
EITHER WAY, THE ANALYST GETS THE
CALL SAYING YOU HAVE SOMETHING
TO WRITE TONIGHT TO GET TO THE
PRESIDENT TOMORROW MORNING.
AND SHE PULLS TOGETHER FROM THE
CIA PERSPECTIVE HERE ARE THE
THREATS RELATED TO THE UNITED
STATES FROM BIN LADEN AND HERE
IS WHAT WE CAN SAY ABOUT WHY WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT THREAT
SERIOUSLY.
NOW, THE THREAT FROM A TERRORIST
GROUP OR ANYTHING IS REALLY
COMPRISED OF TWO PARTS.
IT'S THE THREAT AND THE
OPPORTUNITY.
BUT THE THREAT IS BROKEN DOWN
ITSELF INTO THE INTENT AND THE
CAPABILITY.
YOU MAY REALLY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING, BUT CAN YOU DO IT?
THIS PIECE WAS MOSTLY ABOUT THE
INTENT.
IT WAS ABOUT THE DESIRE TO
ATTACK.
BUT SHE FELT IT WOULD BE
INCOMPLETE IF SHE DIDN'T ANSWER
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
CAPABILITY TO STRIKE IN THE U.S.
SO SHE REACHED OUT TO HER
COUNTERPARTS AT THE FBI TO SEE,
CAN WE PUT SOMETHING IN HERE
ABOUT THE ACTUAL AL QAEDA
PRESENCE IN THE U.S.?
AND BACK THEN IT WAS NOT AN
INTEGRATED INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THE PDB WAS LARGELY A
CIA THING SO SHE GOT INPUT FROM
THE FBI ANALYSTS.
CALLED THE FBI ANALYSTS BACK ON
THE PHONE TO MAKE SURE IT
SOUNDED OKAY AND THAT WAS IT.
IT DID NOT GET VETTED BY SENIOR
FBI OFFICIALS.
PERHAPS IF IT HAD BEEN THERE
MIGHT HAVE BEEN MORE GRANULARITY
ABOUT WHAT WAS KNOWN EVEN THEN
ABOUT AL QAEDA PRESENCE IN THE
U.S.
>> AND WITH THAT RECOMMENDATION
OF MORE INTEGRATION WITH THE
9/11 COMMISSION, THAT'S THE HOPE
THAT PROCESS WOULD BRING TODAY.
I DO WANT TO READ PART OF THIS
MEMO.
IT SAYS CLANDESTINE FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT AND MEDIA REPORTS
INDICATE THAT BIN LADEN WANTED
TO CONDUCT TERRORIST ATTACKS IN
THE U.S.
BIN LADEN APPLIED IN 1997
TELEVISION INTERVIEWS THAT HIS
FOLLOWERS WOULD FOLLOW THE
EXAMPLE OF WORLD TRADE CENTER
BOMBER AND BRING THE FIGHTING TO
AMERICA.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU POINT OUT THIS
HAS A HISTORIC FEEL BUT AT LEAST
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING IN BROAD
TERMS THAT IS SPEAKING TO THE
INTENT AND THE GOAL AND THE
ULTIMATE DESIRE IN THE FUTURE OF
AL QAEDA.
>> YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND, THINKING LIKE A POLICYMAKER
WOULD, LIKE THE PRESIDENT
READING THIS, THE NATURAL
QUESTION THAT COMES IF I READ
SOMETHING IN AUGUST OF 2001 THAT
CITES AN INTERVIEW FROM 1997, MY
FIRST QUESTION IS, WELL, IS IT
STILL AN ACTIVE THREAT?
HOW DO WE KNOW HE STILL INTENDS
TO DO THIS?
AND THIS ARTICLE DOES GO ON TO
EXPLAIN AL QAEDA HAS A VERY LONG
TIMELINE FOR CONDUCTING ATTACKS.
THE EAST AFRICA EMBASSY BOMBINGS
THAT HAPPENED IN 1998, THOSE HAD
BEEN PLANNED FOR YEARS AND AL
QAEDA WAS NOT DETERRED BY
SETBACKS ALONG THE WAY.
SO IT'S A WAY OF TELLING THE
PRESIDENT, BIN LADEN HAS SAID
THIS.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME SECRET
INTELLIGENCE REPORTING
SUPPORTING THAT HE WANTS TO
ATTACK IN THE U.S.
AND DON'T BE FOOLED BY THE FACT
THAT IT HASN'T HAPPENED YET
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LONG
TIMELINE SO THE INTENT IS ALMOST
CERTAINLY STILL THERE.
>> AS A LOT OF PEOPLE INVOLVED
IN THE WAR IN AFGHANISTAN HAVE
REFLECTED ON, YOU KNOW, WHAT WAS
ACHIEVED HERE IN THE LAST TWO
DECADES?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'LL
HEAR PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE
ARCHITECTURE OF IT WILL SAY TO
JUSTIFY IS THEY'LL SAY, LOOK, WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANOTHER 9/11-STYLE
ATTACK.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT ON U.S.
SOIL.
THAT MAKES IT A SUCCESS.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT ASSESSMENT AND ALSO ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD HERE AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF AVOIDING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN THE NEAR
AND EVEN LONG-TERM.
>> YEAH.
THERE NO DOUBT HAVE BEEN
COUNTLESS LIVES SAVED IN THE
TIME SINCE 9/11 DUE TO ENHANCED
COUNTERTERRORIST EFFORTS.
AND FOR ANYBODY TO SAY THAT THE
INVESTMENT THAT WE MADE AS A
COUNTRY, THAT THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO SERVED IN AFGHANISTAN, THAT
IT WAS A WASTE, THEY HAVEN'T
TALKED TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
ARMED FORCES WHO HAVE ACTUALLY
HELD THAT AFGHAN CHILD AND
HELPED THEM GET TO SCHOOL.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT WITH THE TALIBAN IN
POWER FOR THOSE 20 YEARS.
THEY ALSO DON'T THINK ABOUT THE
ATTACK IN 2006 WHERE MULTIPLE
AIRLINERS WERE TAKEN DOWN WITH
LIQUID EXPLOSIVES OVER THE
ATLANTIC OCEAN AND PERHAPS 1,500
PEOPLE DIED.
THEY DON'T REMEMBER THAT BECAUSE
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM 9/11 AND IF
EFFORTS IN THE COUNTERTERRORISM
REALM HELPED PREVENT THAT AND
MANY, MANY OTHER ATTACKS.
CERTAINLY THERE'S BEEN NO OTHER
MAJOR ATTACK IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, FROM
BEING IN THE COUNTERTERRORIST
CENTER BEFORE AND AFTER 9/11, I
WOULD HAVE PREDICTED THAT WITH
WHAT WE ALREADY KNEW ABOUT AL
QAEDA, WHAT WE ALREADY KNEW
ABOUT THEIR WORLDWIDE PRESENCE
AND THEIR DETERMINATION TO
ATTACK AND ATTACK AGAIN, IT
SEEMED A NEAR CERTAINTY THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO PULL OFF A
MAJOR ATTACK IN THE U.S. BECAUSE
THEY ONLY NEED TO GET LUCKY ONCE
IN A WHILE TO PULL OFF AN
ATTACK.
THEY CAN FAIL 100 TIMES.
THEY ONLY NEED ONE TO WORK TO
GET THOSE HEADLINES.
THE FACT THAT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
IS A CREDIT TO THE UNITED
STATES' MILITARY EFFORTS
OVERSEAS, TO DIPLOMATS, TO
EVERYONE WHO WORKED ON THE
COUNTERTERRORIST EFFORT AFTER
9/11.
WE SHOULD NOT LOSE SIGHT OF THAT
JUST BECAUSE THE EXPERIENCE IN
AFGHANISTAN ENDED SO BADLY.
>> YEAH.
MAYBE SOMETHING TO THINK OF AS
WE PUT O